[Music]
you know this scene from The Wizard of
Oz
[Music]
it happens just after Dorothy croons in
sepia tone Kansas total wags his tail
and the house gets caught in a tornado
she travels from a faded filmstrip to a
Technicolor world but there are three
things about this scene you might get
wrong and each one helps show the real
history of Technicolor these
misconceptions explain what the
Technicolor triumph really was from the
technical aspects that made it work to
exactly why it took over the movies to
the way in which the technology shaped
the look of the 20th century line number
one Wizard of Oz is not the first
Technicolor movie not even close
you might know that but a lot of people
don't come on Maryland Science Center
you're better than this historian
barbara fluke adjure has an exhaustive
timeline of color and film from
hand-painted film to the first movie
filmed in kinemacolor a visit to the
seaside but Technicolor stood out and
even it has a history that long predates
The Wizard of Oz Herbert Kalmus Daniel
Frost Comstock and W Burton West Kahn
founded the company in 1914 with the
tech referring to MIT where calmus and
Comstock met it started by merging red
and green into a new image that roughly
looked like this
you can see the look in this range of
movies from the late 1920s and early 30s
it could do possibly well with skin
tones but there's no blue in these
dresses for a reason blue came into the
mix in 1932 when Technicolor added the
key third strip they showed off the
process and Walt Disney's flowers and
trees a gorgeous animated feature that
was a botanists nightmare you know there
are evil trees in The Wizard of Oz too
anyway in order to get Technicolor to
work it was an insanely difficult
process Technicolor distributed guides
like these and we can make a reasonable
simulation digitally with a scene like
this so here's a scene of some lego
people who are apparently worship being
Lawrence of Arabia not sure what's going
on here but it's our starting image a
Technicolor camera would typically take
that picture and shoot it through a
prism that split the light into red blue
and green negatives for the picture
these negatives were then flipped into
positive matrices which eventually got
soaked with dyes of the complementary
colors so the red matrix turned tsiyon
the green one magenta and the blue one
yellow then the dye was transferred this
was called a dye transfer process to
create a final gorgeous Technicolor
image so if you're anything like me that
explanation might make you feel like the
Scarecrow so let's try it again but when
we look at the red Channel
so keep your eye on the viewmaster the
red in the Rubik's Cube or maybe the
Lego guy's hat it is all kind of dark
now because that's just the red color in
the negative now flipped in the matrix
that red is really bright which means
that when it's dyed it won't get a lot
of sian
and that makes sense cyan is the
complementary color
it's the anti red so where you want a
lot of red you do not want a lot of
science that way when it comes together
you get a ton of magenta and some yellow
you don't have a lot of science the
sciences out the red in the earlier days
of Technicolor they also had to amp up
the contrast the company would add a
black and white layer underneath the
matrices to serve as something called
the key you can see the results early in
films like 1934 slit Cucaracha the trail
of The Lonesome Pine and Robin Hood all
of which came out well before the Wizard
of Oz it's easy enough to roughly copy
the technology that Technicolor gave
Wizard of Oz RGB split color bath mesh
repeat but the filmstrip processes are
just part of the story line number 2
this scene it's not going from a black
and white world to a color one the set
was actually painted sepia tone so the
same Technicolor process could be used
for the bright oz reveal today it's much
easier I can draw a box with my hand and
with a click black and white and color
play together they even had techniques
to do stuff like this in the Oz days but
the fact that they built a sepia house
shows how Technicolor's technical
limitations shaped
all color movies
[Music]
this is one of the cameras that was used
to film The Wizard of Oz it weighs four
to five hundred pounds and these cameras
were bigger than ordinary motion picture
cameras because they had to run three
strips of film through them at any given
time so remember this scene that had to
be done with this beast of a camera
those three strips didn't just require
more space they needed tons of light
that said had to be blazingly over lit
to get enough light through to these
three strips of film the sevens
reportedly 100 degrees Fahrenheit at
times sound was an issue - it's so loud
when you're running three strips of film
through a camera so they had to build
this blimp around it that's filled with
soundproofing material so when you're
making a sound film you don't get all
the sound from the camera well let's do
together Technicolor's advantages
outweigh its limitations its main
advantage was the way in which it could
capture the tone of the scene two movies
made in the same year could have a
different look not just because of the
choices made in front of the camera
Technicolor consultants and directors
tweaked the palette of the film by
adjusting the cyan magenta and yellow
dyes the complicated dye transfer
process gave singin in the rain some of
its magenta hewed skin and deep
saturated colors the film and Technology
weren't the only things that gave
Technicolor movies their distinctive
look it also shaped the world that they
chose to fill
line number three this isn't the real
Dorothy its judy garland's bodied Oh
[Music]
she wore specially designed clothes and
makeup to match the sepia world so Judy
Garland could swoop in in the same shot
and a blue dress to join Technicolor
odds
these movies and oz were shaped around
Technicolor's abilities from head to toe
the second page that you see here is the
part of the script that shows the ruby
slippers being unveiled but when it
shows is that there's still silver shoes
at this point but the producers of the
film really wanted to show off that
Technicolor that they were paying for so
they wanted them to be sparkly ruby
slippers that would look good against
the old break room so they change it in
the middle of production - ruby slippers
today the shoes are kept under low light
to preserve them but during the shoot
they were blasted with light to
accommodate the camera and make those
sequins Sparkle these weren't just on
set decisions Technicolor was always
pulling strings behind the curtains look
at the credits for The Wizard of Oz and
the trail of The Lonesome Pine and a
star is born and so on and so on you'll
see one name over and over Nataly calmus
once married to Technicolor co-founder
herb Kalmus she ruled with an iron fist
/ Technicolor productions for many of
the early years
Camas had over 300 film credits where
she gave Technicolor advice and
sometimes told directors what to do this
is the IMDB page for a woman born in
1882
[Music]
in documents like color consciousness
she extended her reach into art the
essay includes aesthetic color theory
red danger blood life he green nature
outdoors freedom freshers calluses
influence was significant but it's as
important as a reflection of
Technicolor's power Technicolor had its
own processing facilities and its own
camera crew that continued Nathalie
calluses work after she left the company
the technology in the production process
gave Technicolor a significant
competitive advantage to alternatives
being used despite all those
alternatives shown on barbara fluke
atures website studio stuck with
Technicolor for a long time it had a
reliable system and could be shown in
any theater in splendid color without
requiring special equipment Technicolor
eventually fell to cheaper processes
through the 1950s like Eastman color
they'd used a single strip The Godfather
Part two was one of the final major
releases to use the Technicolor we
recognized but old prints remained
surprisingly vibrant today due to the
dye transfer process used today I can
snap my fingers and be in the matrix or
in stranger things upside down okay what
are all these dust particles is this
asbestos am I covered in asbestos right
now
Technicolor was never just quick the
look was formed by the cameras strengths
and weaknesses the artistic choices made
for color and the Technicolor company's
infrastructure and supervision in that
key scene from The Wizard of Oz you
might not have known the trivia about
Dorothy's double or the sepia doorway or
even that it wasn't Technicolor's debut
but one thing is easy to understand
intuitively the movie is all about it
Technicolor wasn't a switch or a doorway
it was a whole world just waiting on the
other side
you can nerd out a lot more on
Technicolor by checking out Barbara
fluke atures website or Eastman House
which was really generous with their
time in a lot of the images that you saw
in this video linked both of those below
you can see the director's commentary
for this video in an additional video
that we've made where I share some
behind-the-scenes info and a few of the
details that couldn't quite fit in
[Music]